das ist dein Power rate danke das ist
mein Power
rid lecker
ne wie hoch geht der wie viel skel steht
das da drauf was
nein hallo man sieht
mich also hallo hier sind Kelly und
Vanessa und wir testen heute den
chilisßen Adventskalender will mal ganz
kurz gucken was der gekostet hat ja
gerne würde auch mal
interessiert schon nicht mehr reden 3990
preislich was sagen sie zu Preis super
für ein Kalender ja ne ich geil oh nee
4990 zu viel okay ich bin bereit zu
schwitzen wie gut bist du mit scharfen
essen sehr gut seit unser Korean
Obsession bin ich sehr gut mit scharfen
Essen GEW wir haben immer diese
rahmensuppen ja gegessen ja möchtest du
zuerst ja bitte ich habe nie
Adventskalender ich nie ein wir fangen
an mit Türchen Nummer ein ich wette das
erste Pizza of
death ja gut das wird wahrscheinlich
nach Pizza schmecken ja Tropf mal auf
die Scheiße auf Scheiße es gibt nur neun
Stufen
600000 SK
Alarm ja ist
cheers oh die sch kommt die kommt no
wenn der Nugget weg ist er aber geht
also sorry es ist geht viicht haben echt
zu wenig genommen ist
6004 mit was ist es zu vergleichen es
ist das vorletzte was die haben soll sie
nach Pizza schmecken das Problem ist ja
bei scharfen Sachen ich schmeck kein
Pizza ich spür schon die Schärfe ich
glaube wenn man halt mehr genommen hätte
dann wird es viel mehr den Mund ich
glaub wir müssen ein bisschen mehr
nehmen mutiger beim nächsten ich meine
wir sind beim ersten tüchen wir sollten
vielleicht jetzt noch nicht ein
brennendes Maul haben aber ich glaub
schon dass sie ein schocken wollt ein
bisschen mit dem ersten Türchen Nummer
z
pa aber ist es dann also wenn da jetzt
pa Sauce drauf steht ne ist es dann
wirklich für pa nee ne ach so meinst du
das vorhin war für auf Pizza nein oder
ne ich GLB die machen so eher Geschmack
aber cool also wie findest du Design und
so er cool ich finde die Flaschen
bisschen unpraktisch irgendwie für
scharfe Soße rie aber lecker Bo R geil R
irgende nach Nachos Stufe vi
da ordentlich
draufst
mutig ich habe Bock
aber süße man schmeckt wirklich mehr
jetzt aber das liegt glaube ich wirklich
dran dass die andere einfach endlos heiß
ist und die ist eher so wirklich ein
Geschmack aber du hättest jetzt nicht
sagen können oh ja das schmeckt ein
bisschen nach pa aber wie hältst du
scharf aus kannst du gut scharf essen
mittlerweile
ja Türchen Nummer D green
beansce das das ist nicht so scharf wie
das vorher quasi das einfach nur mit
Chil geil Jalapeno scherfe mag ich das
ist die Liebe es auch bei Nachos im Kino
sich immer die Jalapenos so echt
abzufressen ich mag japenos leider nicht
so aber Jalapenos ist auf jeden Fall
noch mal eine andere Stärke also
Geschmacksrichtung als so rote Chilis ne
Jalapeno chili ist einfach Jalapeno
Chili die einfach Jalapeno heißt aber
eigentlich ist die Jalapeno Chili oder
ist Jalapeno was ganz anderes als Chili
ne ich glaube es ist eine Chili cheers
Chili
cheers vier vier vier vier vier ja und
wie scharf scharf war die jetzt also
fast gar nicht im Vergleich zu den
anderen das ist den eins bitte meinst du
das eine ein auch drin Ketchup oder was
Tomate ist auch Chili oder
F
SP ma den
Kaffee scharfer Kaffee da komm
morgenilette besonders gut komm Kaffee
und scharf nicht PK ist nicht mal pkin
drin ne
ich das pumpkin überhaupt nicht ich
glaub das nur wegen der Farbe haben die
das glaube ich nur so genannt ja so
bisschen weihnachtlich them ne Pizza
pa schmeckt auf jeden Fall anders als
die Pizza scharf scharf ja jetzt lagern
die auch alle so ein bisschen
übereinander schon scharf ja also
schmeckt auf jeden Fall alles ist alles
eine andere Art von Schärfe also hapen
Habanero und Chili ist immer anders
irgendwie
num in beef das ein heftiger Name ne
nein das ist neun warum packen die da
schon neu rein aber wir müssen jetzt
auch so viel weiß du warum da ist
Carolina Reaper und Trin Scorpion dran
also die beiden schärfsten Chilis die im
kompletten Kalender sind hier
verarbeitet so jetzt kippen wir auch
rauf ne ja ja ja okay ich will das diesm
auch schmecken warte ich ma BEWEI das
will das auch morgen noch spüren in
meinem
voll mutig okay W and beef Rest beef
einfach rein ich glaube kommt noch ich
glaube
auch angelaufen oh
no
kommt wieso verteilt sich das auch immer
weiter im Mund es wird immer krasser oh
mein Gott das wird echt immer
krass oh mein got aber weißt du was ich
jetzt meine das fühlt sich so an als ob
du Sonnenbrand im Mund hast oder so boah
jetzt habe ich Kreislauf bei mir geht's
aber auch nach unten jetzt langsam
wollen wir ein nagget zum Spülen Essen
komm ein zum
Spülen Bo hast du voll weh dieser Nugget
fühlt sich an als H der so Spitzen what
mein Gaumen fühlt sich an als wä der
offen so richtig als hättest Du so eine
zu heiße Pizza reingebissen und spürst
es am nächsten Tag noch war erst so
Nummer F ja scheiße Soße Nummer 6
Mexican Sauce mit zwei Chipotle Chili
als ob die gewusst hätten dass davor der
du das nacheinander einfach
wegschallerst lecker
[Musik]
schmecker ja bei diesem schärfelgraden
schmeckt man auch noch was auch so ein
bisschen mehr barbecueig irgendwie aber
ehrlich gesagt schmeckt ein bisschen
nach als wir New York bei Ch potle
gegessen haben ich bin ganz schmeckt
nicht me so viel aber ja ich weiß was
z das war Nikolaus ja gut war süß ja
sauerbratensoße 7 hier ist eine Chili
namens B yolokia drin hört sich krank an
aber sie wir haben die neuen überlebt
vielleicht auch ganz gut sonst hätten
wir vielleicht so Schiss die ganit davor
gehabt wir haben die neuen überlebt ne
war krank wir überleben
alles
so richtig
so n mehr den ganzen also nur als Beweis
wir klat den ganzen
Nug ja chilisen Experten werden
unwischen so haten
warum nicht
diee Freunde der genusultur und des
kulturgenusses hast du eigentlich
scharfe Soße auf dem Nacken ach
so wie findest du den Kalender optisch
ich finde ih sehr sehr süß ja oh geil
ich lieb es wenn die grün sind wenn die
grün sind sind super smoky Lemon Sauce
mit 12% geräucherte Amarillo und
zitronenschein Zitronengras hier ist
wenigstens Zitrone drin und also wei du
beim Kürbis war nicht Kürbis drin ver
ich auch nicht bis heute Kürbis auch
nicht ch aber sowas kann ich mir auch
wieder sehr gut zum mexikanischem Essen
vorstellen ne oh ja weil ich frage mich
auch wozu istst man diese scharfen Soßen
außer zu Wings weißt
du gefällt mir bisschen parfümiert habe
ich das Gefühl ne ne darfst du aufmachen
okay Nummer ist mein lieblingstürchen
und Türchen Nummer 9 ist immer das Beste
drin
nugg
nein vi Nuggets Soße endlich das wofür
jetzt frage ich mich aber auch ob diese
Soße jetzt besser schmeckt zu Nugget als
die anderen Soßen das halt auch die
Frage noch
mehr nö finde ich jetzt nicht würde ich
jetzt nicht sagen ist eine
nuggetsße Mist wir eher so seafood Sauce
irgendwie so SEAG ja in der Zeh befindet
sich ihr dürft zuerst gucken ja ich weiß
nicht was es ist was ist es denn hot
pastaauce oh auch lecker auf Pasta
meinst du wirklich die mein also es
könnte ja schon sein ne dass sie dann so
sagen das schon jetzt mittlerweile
glaube ich tatsächlich dass ist auf was
du das drauf machen kan oh das rie nach
pastasauße guck mal wie s voll aus dem
nagetrmus ich habe immer einen halben
wenn du ein ganzen hast weil ich habe
nur ein halben bei dem K gessen Blackout
gewesen Stufe 3 geil da sind sogar
richtige
gewürzstückchen drauf ja
ja m m ich würde aber nicht in Pasta
reinmachen sonst würde er der ganze
geschmackföten gehen das finde ich jetzt
eher die pizzasoße m 11elf Coconut
shrimp Sauce geil wow se falls ihr nicht
wisst was Coconut Shrimps sind in meinem
Kochbuch was in meiner videeschreib nein
echt gibt Coconut
shrims meine Finger sind immer aus das
so richtig böse so
oh welche Nummer hat es sechs sechs
lecker
[Musik]
das schmeckt das geräucherte ja bisschen
sch wo sind wir den jetzt 12 Hälfte des
Kalenders er oh mein Gott schon bisschen
fertig jetzt ich glaube jetzt wird
anstrengend Nummer 12 ich finde aber
dafür halten wir das echt gut aus
R wenn ihr ein Rezept für ein tolles
ratatoui haben wollt in meinem
K das
ratatoui aus
ratati ich letztens noch ratat geguckt
und ich finde ist wirklich pixas Magnus
Opus das heißt der geilste Film von den
eöt ratatoui ist ein Nummer 5 hier das
Knallen wir uns ja morgens schon rein
kein Körper sagt was anderes gerade Du
findest ratatoui auf jeden Fall 100% der
beste pixarfilm aller Zeiten und danach
kommt findet Nemo und alles steht Kopf
cheers komm nicht mal annähend
dran tomatewi Pfeffer Paprika und
Knoblauch ja wo sind wir jetzt 13 Fried
Chicken Sauce a oh gar
kein vor allem ich glaube ich darf nur
ein Viertel Nugget jetzt nur noch essen
weil sonst komm es nicht hin mit meinen
Nuggets ich muss aber auch oh ich muss
aber auch den nächsten müssen Drittel
ein Drittel musst du machen oh das hast
du voll viel drauf gemacht
[Musik]
ja ich habe schon wieder halben
abgeemissen oder kommt wieder ja ein
bisschen das ist eine trinidat Scorpion
ja der klettert langsam hoch der
Scorpion 14 Bo das sieht aus als wür
Nagel gleich
abbrechen der
Scorpion na schnell oh Sushi saauce
koriander ist
drin vi angenehm so jetzt bei nur die
Stückchen
ab tut weh auf den noch schz drauf das
steigt immer weiter ja fresh ein
bisschen fischig irgendwie Koriander
Inga so ein bisschen asiatisch
angehaucht ist die gar nich 15 du wir
schaffen das ohne Milch zu holen hier
das ist was fürs Weihnachtsfest
rolladensoßeol drei guck mal das ist ja
gar
nichts nur die Ecke hier roladensoße y
mitapen wieder aber d wir uns einfach
ohne jetzt mit der Wimper zu Zen 24
Chicken Wings
einballern 12 A so
stimm ist das alles Schar aber jetzt
habe ich auf einmal wieder was
geschmeckt kurz aber nur eine Sekunde
Alter mein Gaumen ist verbrannt
verschwefelt und wieder zugewachsen und
wieder aufgerissen worden ah 16 u oh
endlich was ist das was für endlich
kuchensoße ach so mit eins
Bless
America die sieht am allergefährlichsten
aus wie kann die denn nur eins
haben das sieht aus wie eine chilisoßce
aus dem
[Musik]
supermarktetchup Warum auf flkuchen
verstehe ich nicht weiß ich auch nicht
Burger Sauce 2 ey ich liebe
Burger bisschen aufgedreht B jetzt jetzt
ich werde ich bisschen verrückt langsam
was machst du denn mit so vielen Soßen
ich glaub Essen ich find die eigentlich
ganz geil alle geil
che brauche ich sehr aber bis jetzt so
der Zwischenstand finde ich es ein
geiler Kalender ein
Erlebnis sieht so brutal aus wie du dein
Nagel da immer reinchiebst ich komme
nicht klar burning Canape okay ja okay
erstal gut ach ich brauche das gerade
nicht in meinem Leben das ist immer wenn
der Schmerz gerade weg ist und ich
wieder was was schmecken kann Schall die
mir wieder eine ach rein hät auch
bisschen sparsamer sein können ehrlich
gesagt tomatisch kommt wieder nix gleich
wieder die Hölle los hier das ist
nämlich das Problem bei diesem wirklich
scharfen Soßen die schmecken am Anfang
nicht scharf da ist doch nichts gerade
so wir machen schnell weiter das kommt
jetzt erst das ist jetzt alles super
19 hotwing Sauce das ist die haben Fried
Chicken die haben Chicken Nugget und
jetzt noch hotwing Sauce also wirklich
ja aber ich glaub also zu scharfen soen
ist man auch gerne Wings einfach es
kommt bei mir noch nicht die Schärfe mal
gucken die Achter und wir haben
ordentlich drauf gekippt sch ist tüchen
mein Amazon Paket ja F hat sie ach so
was S ich jetzt alleine oder was
okay ma ich alle ich ma einfach ja ma
hotwingng Sauce das müsste eigentlich
die beste sein die die ist nicht so
meins GLB ich einfach nicht was ist
jetzt gerade scharf die
Canapes okay Kelly rastet aus Schnauze
ich weiß nicht was ist war die 19 die
hotwingng Sauce stimmt die habe ich noch
nicht
[Musik]
vergessen ich find aber auch habanus
lecker Nummer
20 roasted Lobster roasted
lobsters die riecht lecker was für
Nummer
vi das die Version von dieser Dumbledor
szeneer
dies du musst aufessen Kelly ich g
mehr das ich das ist gar nichts mehr für
mich das ist einfach nur eine Soße 21
wir können wir erst bei 21 sein s honey
chicken Sauce jetzt denken sich das auch
mit also jetzt wiederholt sich nei h
okay warum so viel
nur Nummer s willst du 22 aufmachen oder
darf ich ja me Z meine Lieblingszahl 22
zwei und deswegen wenn es zwei zwei gibt
ist es noch besser okay dann wird jetzt
hier das beste drin
sein ist doch deine Schuld Hellfire
Sauce
hellf bin traumatisiert Carolina R
dieses videohen wenn ich hier bin weißt
du da dachtest du n die zieh ich mit ins
Verderben die alte Sau nicht so
viel ist einfach jede drin das Carolina
R Scorpion und
Habanero das muss aber krasser sein als
Hot ones das was wir machen WE bei HOT
ones haben die vielleicht neun
socen und wir haben ging 24 aber ich
glaube die Soßen die sie auch da haben
da nicht die Soßen zum Ende irgendwas
Millionen ja ich ich mus konzentrieren
sonst kippe ich um ich spüre die neuen
nicht die neuen nicht mehr Currywurst
Sauce die vorletzte ist das jetzt okay
das ist zwei das ist doch super oh oh
die das kommt alles ein bisschen später
an bei mir jetzt mittlerweile ja die
neuen meldet sich gerade bei mir auch
okay
Currywurst
Currywurst schmeckt auch wie Currywurst
so mein Gast mus ist die erste wo ich
wirklich sage schmeckt so wie es drauf
steht also 24 ja machen wir das Finale
ja du bist jetzt dran und in der 24 da
freuen wir uns
ganz die Karte ist drin oh gott sei Dank
ich dachte das ist so eine warnungskarte
ey so mit mit herzsprottmacher nicht
essen oder so weißt du se roasted beef
irgendwie nicht so weihnachtlich ne doch
oder roast beef istst man doch ist doch
so ein schickes Gericht oder für
Weihnachten roast beef ja könn sein
Habanero ich hasse Habanero habe ich
schon mal gesagt auch Chipotle ist
drin man hätte eigentlich zwei Runden
machen können erst ein bis ze oder so
aufsteigend Mitte der Z ist die die neun
und dann wieder nach unten und dann
wieder langsam nach oben
vielleichttimt sind auch besser ganz
viel haben wir drauf
Beweis okay wie hat dieser Kalender
gefallen Kelly ja ich danke dir wirklich
für diese wahnsinnig tolle Erfahrung ich
dachte zwischendrin ich muss wirklich
drauf gehen kurz ja ich glaube ich werde
wirklich zu kämpfen haben heute ich
glaub Rest des Tages der Magen ist jetzt
auch voll angegriffen ne ist ja
eigentlich voll der schlechte was
eiglich scheiße wie viel Uhr ist es
eigentlich das Gefühl wir okay wir
müssen gehen also es war toll wir drehen
auch noch kin Video das seht ihr dann in
paar Tagen auf 200 Jahren
tschüss